cops love getting videotaped they'll
never admit it but they secretly loved
being on camera which is why First
Amendment Auditors are universally loved
throughout the country it's not
controversial at all now the
introduction of smartphones his
revolutionized citizens ability to
document the misconduct of police
officers and public officials in real
time and with the Advent of social media
these videos that shine a light on
police brutality such as Eric Garner
Walter Scott and George Floyd can go
viral bringing instant attention to the
film's subjects and even Fame to the
photographer and fun fact before the
Advent of smartphones police never
infringed on anyone's First Amendment
rights at least according to the police
but in recent years the filming of
police has evolved into a growing social
movement and online subculture known as
first amendment audits where citizens
Auditors film their own encounters with
government employees in public spaces to
test whether the filmmaker's
constitutional rights will be respected
or or violated First Amendment Auditors
cast themselves as patriotic activists
and citizen journalists fighting for
transparency accountability and open
government this is an entire genre on
YouTube
get somebody tell you to leave and then
if you don't leave you'll have to go to
jail is that what you want no I don't
want that
let's not let's not violate my rights
fellas let's go ahead and hop back in
your little vehicles and have a nice day
you're interfering with the
drive-through well you can say you
wouldn't but you were
inshallah
assalamualaikum I don't mind you doing
that but they're making the bank people
nervous so if you want to stand down
where there's no businesses absolutely
not you're not going to violate My First
Amendment rights to free speech on a
public sidewalk we understand that there
needs to be law enforcement people are
out there doing bad things but when you
have police officers deputies Troopers
doing the same damn thing as the people
in the streets that is an unsustainable
system and
but critics argue that first amendment
audits are not about defending the
Constitution as much as they are a
cynical vehicle for monetizing online
outrage and unfairly maligning public
servants many Auditors can and do make
thousands of dollars per month from
their viral confrontations videos that
are often peppered with profanity and
other deliberately provocative Behavior
so who's right here well it depends
documenting police and public spaces
finds its roots in cop watching a Civil
Rights era practice in which groups of
private citizens patrolled urban
communities with cameras to document any
police misconduct but in the mid-2000s
First Amendment auditing began to take
shape just as handheld digital and
smartphone cameras were becoming widely
available typically videos documenting
public misconduct have come from
citizens who happen to be at the right
place at the right time such was the
case with darnella Fraser who at 17
years old recorded officer Derek Chauvin
kneeling on George Floyd's neck for
nearly 10 minutes but what
differentiates First Amendment Auditors
from spontaneous recordings like
fraziers is that Auditors deliberately
seek out encounters with public
officials rather than filming misconduct
they just happen to witness First
Amendment auditor Zoe Perez who goes by
the name furry potato on YouTube summed
up the goal of auditing as follows quote
it's not only about shining a light on
the Crooked bad cops but shining an even
brighter light on the good cops you put
yourself in places where you know
chances are the cops are going to be
called are they going to uphold the
Constitution or break the law one of the
earliest First Amendment audit groups
was photography is not a crime or pineac
a florida-based News website and
advocacy Group which focuses on the
right to film police pineac was created
in 2007 after its founder veteran
photojournalist Carlos Miller was
arrested for photographing a group of
five Miami police officers conducting a
traffic investigation when the police
officers asked Miller to leave and stop
filming them Miller reminded the
officers that this was a public road and
continued taking photos Miller claims
the officers then threw him to the
ground and viciously beat him the
officers arrested Miller and charged him
with nine misdemeanors including
resisting arrest Miller who would be
arrested four times in seven years for
his work ultimately was acquitted of all
charges including having his 2007
resisting arrest conviction overturned
on appeal in recent years though First
Amendment Auditors don't just film
police officers rather they regularly
enter State local and federal buildings
from libraries to post offices just to
see how government officials react to
the camera lens so what does is a
traditional First Amendment audit look
like well as the Washington Post writes
in his purist form the auditor simply
stands in a public space films or as is
often the case live streams the
encounter with staff and customers alike
and then refuses to put down the camera
or explain or identify themselves if an
officer approaches if there is no
confrontation or request to stop filming
the facility passes the audit but if an
employee attempts to stop filming then
the facility fails the audit that's what
First Amendment auditor accountability
for all did in its 2019 review of the
Foxboro Police Department in
Massachusetts audits like this can be
great press for the locality when the
public officials respect individual
rights which is what happened in Foxboro
accountability for all gave the Foxboro
OPD a glowing review and it was written
about in the local newspaper other
audits though can result in arrests or
injury to the auditor in February 2019
furry potato AKA Zoe Perez was
accidentally shot by a security guard
during an impromptu First Amendment
audit outside a Los Angeles synagogue as
Perez live streamed the encounter a
synagogue security guard standing behind
the gate had his weapon drawn for four
minutes yelled at Perez to get away and
then fired a warning into the ground
causing the bullet fragment to strike
her in the leg prosecutors declined to
file charges stating that they lack
sufficient proof that the security guard
used unreasonable force in this case
it's worth noting that furry potato
wasn't actually conducting a First
Amendment audit per se the synagogue
security guard wasn't a police official
or government employee at all instead he
was a private contractor so furry
potatoes First Amendment rights were
actually never in question or infringed
upon even so artists like this could be
valuable for what they tell us about
public safety and accountability
certainly more so in and around actual
government buildings but let's talk
about the legality of First Amendment
audits when is it legal to film public
officials it should come as little
surprised that the police do not take
kindly to being recorded despite what
the introduction to this video actually
said now many police organizations
opposed citizens recording them in the
course of their duties claiming that it
puts their safety at risk and interferes
with active police work some officers
even tell citizens that filming them is
illegal and like what happened to Mr
Miller of pineac will arrest First
Amendment Auditors while filming but is
recording the police or public spaces
actually illegal well contrary to what
this North Carolina police officer told
this lawyer during a traffic stop
filming police is not illegal and you
actually do have a First Amendment right
to record sir can you tell me what this
new law is that I'm not allowed to
record
I'm sorry he said that there's a law I'm
not allowed to record the police I just
wanted to know what that new law is you
said you were returning correct I am
I've never heard of this law that you're
not allowed to record the police anymore
it must be brand new okay well they just
recently
like super recently seems like a strange
law by the way I know that finding a
great lawyer can be really hard but
that's until now my firm the eagle team
is now accepting new clients if you've
been injured or just need a lawyer we
can represent you or help you find the
right attorney because you don't need a
legal team you need the eagle team just
check out the link in the description
for that now back to First Amendment
Auditors oh boy and while the Supreme
Court has not directly ruled on this
matter Federal appellate courts in the
first third fifth seventh ninth and 11th
circuits have upheld the right to record
public officials in the course of their
duties the primary rationale for
allowing the recording of public
officials is the first amendment audit
right to freely discuss our government
and the people's right to access
information about their officials public
activities in the case of Smith versus
city of [__] the 11th circuit
articulated the reasoning writing quote
the first amendment protects the right
to gather information about what public
officials do on public property and
specifically a right to record matters
of public interest courts have also
upheld filming public officials on the
grounds that freedom of the the Press
applies to Citizen journalists and
documentarians just as much as it does
the formal members of the press
especially since more and more news is
actually being gathered and disseminated
by citizens with smartphones this was
the seven circuits logic in the ACLU
versus Alvarez reasoning that private
citizens right to make quote an audio or
audio visual recording and then their
quote right to disseminate the resulting
recording of police officers performing
their public duties falls under the
first amendment protection of gathering
news and information particularly about
the Affairs of the government however
that's not always the case in all
circumstances now the great weight of
case law clearly supports the First
Amendment right to record public
officials in the course of their duties
in a way that doesn't interfere with
those duties however First Amendment
rights are not unlimited and there are
instances where recording could violate
the Law Courts upholding the right to
record have also held that police May
reasonably restrict some First Amendment
rights according to what's generally
called a Time play and manner
restrictions examples of time place and
Mana restrictions include imposing
limits on the noise level of speech
barring early morning or late night
protests or restricting the size or
placement of signs on government
property generally these are content
neutral restrictions that they're not
punishing any particular kind of speech
they are just limiting the time place
and manner of the speech or the
recording for example in Garrick versus
vegan the First Circuit Court of Appeals
while acknowledging the right to film a
traffic stop also held that reasonable
time place and Mana restrictions on the
right to film may be imposed when the
circumstances justify them in the
context of First Amendment Auditors
police officers might curb the right to
film quote only if the officer can
reasonably conclude that the filming
itself is interfering or is about to
interfere with his duties per Garrick
police officers May reasonably limit the
right to record to maintain safety and
control with incidental effects on First
Amendment rights such as commanding
bystanders to disperse from a traffic
stop up when a detained individual is
armed police officers might also be able
to arrest Auditors who commit crimes
during recordings such as disorderly
conduct stalking trespass or harassment
in fact in April 2021 Texas First
Amendment Auditors Joey Perez and Paul
Estrada IV were arrested in connection
with two separate auditing incidents
according to the police and bear in mind
this is coming from the police the pair
had a history of inserting themselves
into active police scenes getting in
close proximity to police and their
vehicles standing in roadways and
Shining lights from their cameras in the
eyes of the police officers and some
Auditors regularly scream profanity
police officers in a provocative way and
have otherwise engaged in activity that
has caused some to be successfully
prosecuted for disorderly conduct in
2019 Jesus Padilla known as Mexican
Padilla on YouTube was convicted on
three counts of disorderly conduct
following an incident in which he
followed three San Antonio SWAT officers
leaving a police station and bombarding
them with profanity and homophobia slurs
Padilla contends that cursing which he
does in many of his videos is
constitutionally protected since he did
not threaten any violence in fact courts
have long held that profane language is
constitutionally protected speech in the
famous case of Cohen versus California
the Supreme Court overturned a man's
breach of the peace conviction after he
was arrested for wearing a jacket
reading [__] the draft in a Los Angeles
courtroom and in 2015 the Washington
Supreme Court reversed a teenager's
conviction for obstructing law
enforcement for yelling calling Seattle
police officers abusive names and using
profanity while the officers
investigated a disturbance which has all
led to criticism of First Amendment
audits in recent Years first amendment
audits have expanded into its own social
media subculture with self-appointed
Auditors live streaming their public
encounters on YouTube and Instagram to
critics these Auditors are not standing
up for constitutional rights as much as
they are interfering with police
officers harassing public employees and
purposefully picking fights for clicks
and cash in a June 2021 video shared
with tens of thousands of followers 32
year old Sean Paul Reyes AKA Long Island
audit filmed at a public library even
though it was unauthorized to film at
the library due to purported privacy
reasons in the video Reyes refused to
budge prompting a confrontation with
Danbury Police and shouts dude why you
got to be such a tyrant
iron
and there are plenty of Auditors like
Reyes who Relish in confrontational
tactics to elicit a reaction from their
subjects this includes berating subjects
with profane language being
intentionally rude and uncooperative
when questioned or engaging in
borderline harassment or intimidation
like openly carrying firearms in public
buildings now many public officials do
acknowledge the right to film if for no
other reason that sometimes First
Amendment Auditors are able to launch
successful lawsuits against State and
public officials for infringing their
first amendment rights and as a result
some state governments and police
organizations issue guidance on how to
respectfully deal with First Amendment
Auditors as to avoid having to pay large
settlements to Auditors other public
officials have found let's say creative
and improper ways to try to limit public
filming for example some public
officials have adopted a tactic to
playing copyrighted songs in an effort
to cause live streaming videos to get
automatically blocked by Instagram or or
YouTube for example in 2021 First
Amendment auditor Senate devermont who
runs the Instagram account always film
the police live streamed himself
delivering a foia request to the Beverly
Hills to the police department however
in two separate encounters a sergeant
pulled out his phone to blast Sublime
Santa Rita while being filmed seemingly
aware of what he was doing and while
that police officer may not practice
Santeria he appeared to have a crystal
ball
other police officers made headlines
when they blasted Taylor Swift during an
arrest other localities have instituted
time place and Mana restrictions in 2020
the City of Tucson Arizona passed an
ordinance allowing officers to designate
a restricted area around a crime scene
within which it is illegal to knowingly
interfere with law enforcement in the
course of their official duties the
ordinance was enacted in response to
footage showing a First Amendment
auditor berating a female Tucson officer
with several minutes of uninterrupted
profanities and gendered slurs during a
traffic stop according to the chief of
police the traffic stop in the viral
video involved a car full of robbery
suspects and the ordinance sought to
prevent Auditors from interfering with
police work two years later the Arizona
State House passed a bill making it
illegal to film police officers within
eight feet reduced from the original
proposal of 15 feet the bill allowed
recording if the individual recording is
at the center of police contact or is an
occupant in a stock vehicle so long as
they don't interfere with the police
action but according to one local
Arizona radio station the bill would
have made the George Floyd bystander
video a crime so this raises the
question our first amendment Auditors
constitutional Warrior spurring real
change or trolls out for profit critics
can point to countless examples of First
Amendment Auditors who appear to be
motivated by fame or clicks or cash
rather than the Constitution even among
those sympathetic to the movement it's
hard to see how harassing patrons at
post offices and public libraries are
filming outside a synagogue serves any
purpose Beyond attempting to go viral
but Auditors are not a monolith and
there's countless individuals auditing
organizations who do good work thanks to
the educational efforts and legal
advocacy of groups like pineac the ACLU
the Electronic Frontier Foundation or
fire the public is well aware of their
constitutional rights to film in public
and although Federal efforts at police
reform have arguably stalled Advocates
can point to real policy change at the
state and local levels thanks to
bystander and audit videos and who knows
how many Untold instances of police
misconduct have been documented thanks
to people with cell phone cameras so
seriously it depends but it's only a
matter of time before another First
Amendment auditor ends up in the news
again which is perfect for today's
sponsor ground news over the past decade
online news and AD driven algorithms
have made it profitable for news outlets
to embrace a position on the bias
Spectrum to Target specific consumers
but ground news was created to offer
Clarity in an increasingly chaotic media
landscape by adding context and
transparency to every new story using a
rating system and gives you a visual
breakdown of the new sources covering a
story and where they fall on the
political Spectrum ground News tells me
how news stories are biased their
factuality rating based on three
independent assessments and even the
ownership of the news Outlet it also
shows you blind spots like which news
stories are being underreported by one
side or the other I use ground news when
I'm researching my videos because I can
ensure that I'm getting all sides using
the most unbiased accurate reporting and
plus I can use it on my computer or on
an app on my phone it helps you to think
for yourself and not be totally driven
by a particular slant of the news that
you're consuming ground news is is not
better news it's a better way to read
the news so click on the link that's on
screen or down in the description to try
ground news for free and get a huge 40
discount when you subscribe to any of
the premium subscriptions that 40
discount is only available through the
link below is the biggest discount
anywhere you'll get the features you see
here support legal eagle and a small
team of Independent Media Outsiders
working to make the news more
transparent so that's it you can use
ground news for free and also get a huge
40 discount on ground news Vantage
subscription by clicking on the link
below and after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court